(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Vamos começar, então, pelo primeiro termo que a
gente vai analisar.
Esse termo é penhora.
O que é penhora?
Penhora é uma conscrição, uma apreensão judicial dos
bens de um devedor para garantir o pagamento
de uma dívida.
Ou seja, a gente já falou que, num
processo judicial, o leilão judicial existe para que
o devedor pague o que ele está devendo
para o credor.
Devedor é o executado, credor é o execuente.
A gente falou também que a lei tem
uma ordem preferencial dos bens do devedor que
vão servir para pagar o valor de uma
dívida.
O primeiro lugar dessa ordem de preferência da
lei, obviamente, é o dinheiro em espécie.
Depois passam para os títulos de dívida pública,
com a União, os estados e os municípios.
Depois os títulos privados com cotação e mercado,
como ações da Bolsa de Valores.
Depois a gente passa para os veículos.
Depois dos veículos, os imóveis.
E depois essa lista segue, tendo joias, embarcações,
aeronaves e mais alguns itens.
Então, a penhora vai recair sobre algum bem
do devedor.
Como a gente está estudando aqui imóvel, o
leilão judicial de imóvel, a penhora pode recair
sobre o imóvel de um devedor.
E é exatamente essa penhora que vai fazer
com que o imóvel seja levado a leilão.
Então, o que significa constar uma penhora sobre
o imóvel?
Significa que o Poder Judiciário apreendeu aquele imóvel
e aquele imóvel só pode ser vendido pelo
Poder Judiciário.
O devedor que tenha um imóvel seu com
uma penhora, ele não consegue fazer essa venda
de forma tradicional.
O cartório não registraria essa venda.
Então, o devedor realmente não consegue vender esse
imóvel.
Só o Poder Judiciário vai conseguir vender esse
imóvel, a não ser que o Poder Judiciário
cancele a penhora.
Aí, a propriedade do devedor volta a ser
plena.
A penhora do imóvel, ela necessariamente vai ficar
registrada na macrícula do imóvel.
Por quê?
Porque quando uma penhora recai sobre um bem
imóvel, por exemplo, um carro, é possível que
aquele bem imóvel seja levado para um pátio
da Justiça, por exemplo.
Mas isso não dá para acontecer com um
imóvel.
Você não consegue pegar um imóvel, tirar de
um lugar e levar para as dependências do
Poder Judiciário, para que o Poder Judiciário tome
conta daquele imóvel.
Então, a forma de dar publicidade para a
penhora do imóvel é exatamente registrar essa penhora
na matrícula do imóvel.
A matrícula do imóvel, como a gente já
estudou aqui várias vezes no curso, ela é
um documento público.
Basta que qualquer interessado vá ao cartório de
registro do imóvel e requeira a matrícula daquele
imóvel.
Então, requerendo a matrícula daquele imóvel, verificando que
aquele imóvel tem uma ou mais penhoras, você
sabe que aquele imóvel está indisponível para venda.
Vamos falar assim, que aquele imóvel só pode
ser vendido pelo Poder Judiciário.
E o Poder Judiciário usa para alienar imóveis
justamente o leilão judicial.
Esse registro da penhora na matrícula do imóvel
também é um requisito de publicidade da penhora,
exatamente porque a matrícula é um documento público.
Então, qualquer um pode ter acesso.
E uma informação que qualquer um pode ter
acesso, essa informação é uma informação pública.
O devedor, que é o proprietário, ou que
tem alguma espécie de direitos sobre bens, sobre
direitos, a gente também tem uma aula específica
aqui um pouco mais adiante.
Ele deve ser intimado da penhora de seu
imóvel.
Então, toda vez que um imóvel for penhorado,
o proprietário, ou quem tem direito sobre aquele
imóvel, ele deve ser notificado daquela penhora, ele
deve ser intimado daquela penhora.
Como que ele vai ser intimado?
Quando existe um processo judicial em curso e
esse proprietário é o executado daquele processo, ou
seja, ele é o réu daquele processo, ele
necessariamente, para se defender, ele vai ter que
constituir um advogado.
Então, para se defender, ele vai ter que
ter um advogado falando em nome dele.
Esse advogado, ele pode contratar esse advogado, ou
pode ser um advogado de uma defensoria pública,
por exemplo.
Uma vez que o executado, ou seja, o
réu daquele processo, tem um advogado que fale
por ele naquele processo, ou seja, o réu
passou uma procuração por um advogado, e aquele
advogado está representando o réu naquele processo, o
executado, que é o proprietário do bem, ele
vai ser intimado da penhora através do seu
advogado.
Então, o advogado é intimado e o advogado
é que deve levar essa informação para o
executado.
Se o executado, ele não tiver advogado no
processo, existem muitos processos em que a pessoa
é citada para se defender e deixa o
processo correr à revelia, isto é, ela não
opõe nada naquele processo.
Quando chegar ao fim daquele processo, o leilão
ocorrer, ela vai receber a notificação de desocupação
e vai desocupar aquele imóvel.
Essa pessoa simplesmente não se manifestou naquele processo.
Isso é muito comum.
Se esse for o caso e ele não
tiver um advogado, ele vai ser intimado pessoalmente
e a preferência é para que essa intimação
pessoal dele aconteça por uma carta de intimação.
Essa carta de intimação, ela vai ser enviada
por correios e vai ser enviada com um
aviso de recebimento, que é o AR.
Então, quando o carteiro vai levar essa carta
de intimação para a pessoa, a pessoa recebe
essa carta de intimação e assina esse AR.
O AR vai constar a data que a
pessoa recebeu, a hora e a assinatura dessa
pessoa.
Se essa pessoa morar num condomínio, tudo bem,
quem vai receber esse AR, geralmente, é o
porteiro.
O porteiro vai assinar o AR e essa
intimação vai ser perfeitamente válida, porque o porteiro,
pela lei, ele é um funcionário que tem
poderes para receber esse tipo de intimação.
Então, não tem problema que uma pessoa seja
intimada e quem receba essa intimação seja um
porteiro.
O porteiro deve repassar essa carta de intimação
para o proprietário daquele imóvel.
Essa intimação é um requisito de validade para
que a penhora exista.
Se existir a penhora e não existir a
intimação, isso pode ser um motivo depois de
anular o leilão.
No final desse módulo, a gente vai ter
uma aula prática e nessa aula prática, a
gente vai avaliar dentro de um processo judicial
como é que você vai saber se ocorreu
ou não a intimação do devedor para que
aquela penhora fosse válida e, consequentemente, aquele leilão
fosse válido.
O mesmo imóvel pode ter uma ou várias
penhoras.
Nada impede que um proprietário de um imóvel
deva dívidas de condomínio, dívidas de PTU, dívidas
trabalhistas de sua empresa, dívidas com banco.
Nada impede que aquela pessoa tenha uma gama
de dívidas e todas essas dívidas podem gerar
penhora no imóvel.
Então, nada impede que um imóvel que já
está penhorado, por exemplo, por uma dívida de
condomínio, tenha uma nova penhora por uma dívida
do proprietário com banco.
Um imóvel pode ter várias dívidas.
É normal até, quando o imóvel tem uma
dívida, a gente encontrar na matrícula do imóvel
várias dívidas daquele proprietário.
E qual é a consequência de um imóvel
ter várias penhoras diferentes?
Todos os credores com penhoras em vigência devem
ser notificados da existência do leilão sobre aquele
bem.
Por que isso acontece?
Para que os outros credores possam ter a
possibilidade de habilitar o valor que eles têm
para receber naquele processo que está levando o
imóvel ao leilão e habilitar o crédito.
Nada mais é do que chegar para o
juiz e mostrar, olha, essa pessoa também me
deve.
Eu também tenho uma penhora na matrícula desse
bem.
Então, o valor dessa arrematação também tem que
servir para me pagar.
E pronto.
Ela vai apresentar esse requerimento e depois o
juiz, ao final do leilão, ele vai abrir
o que a gente chama de concurso de
credores.
A gente também tem uma aula específica aqui
de concurso de credores para que vocês possam
entender qual é a preferência de pagamento para
essas dívidas.
Existem dívidas que apesar de ser a última
penhora registrada numa matrícula, ela deve ser paga
em primeiro lugar.
Porque ela é uma dívida preferencial.
A gente vai aprender isso um pouco mais
adiante.
E também, os outros credores com penhora na
matrícula devem ser intimados do leilão que vai
acontecer para impedir algo que antigamente era muito
comum, que era impedir que o mesmo imóvel
fosse a leilão de forma concomitante por determinação
de dois juízes diferentes.
Porque, veja, para existir uma penhora na matrícula
de um imóvel, precisa de um processo judicial.
Então, a gente já falou que o mesmo
proprietário pode dever para dezenas de pessoas diferentes.
Então, vão existir dezenas de processos diferentes.
Um processo que cuida de débito de condomínio.
Outro processo que cuida de dívidas daquela pessoa
com banco.
Outro processo que cuida de dívidas tributárias que
aquele imóvel tenha.
E assim, existem vários processos concomitantes.
O leilão é uma das últimas fases do
processo.
Mas vamos supor que alguns desses processos estejam
nessa fase do leilão ao mesmo tempo.
Nada impede que um juiz A, que está
responsável pela dívida de condomínio, determine o leilão.
E um juiz B, que está responsável por
uma dívida bancária, determine o leilão daquele imóvel.
Então, notificar os outros credores é exatamente para
que isso não ocorra.
Para que todos saibam que o juiz A
está levando aquele imóvel ao leilão.
E todos os outros juízes esperem que aquele
leilão aconteça para saber se aquele leilão vai
ou não ter arrematação.
Se aquele leilão tiver arrematação, o caminho para
os credores buscarem receber o seu crédito é
o que a gente falou anteriormente.
Habilitar o crédito no processo que levou o
imóvel ao leilão.
E aí vai abrir o chamado concurso de
credores.
Qual é a consequência prática de existirem várias
penhoras no mesmo imóvel?
Essas penhoras, elas vão ser canceladas após o
leilão.
Elas vão ser canceladas por quem?
Por ordem do próprio juiz que mandou que
o imóvel fosse a leilão ou pode ser
que esse juiz entenda que como as outras
ordens de penhora não partiram dele e sim
partiram de outros colegas dele, ou seja, outros
juízes que cada um desses juízes vai ter
que determinar o cancelamento da penhora que esse
juiz ordenou.
Então, primeiro você vai tentar falar com o
juiz que ordenou o imóvel para ele cancelar
todas as outras penhoras.
Pode ser que ele fale não.
Olha, quem deve cancelar as outras penhoras são
os outros juízes que determinaram a existência dessa
penhora.
Então, isso não traz maior dificuldade para você
como arrematante.
Você como arrematante vai ter que fazer uma
petição em cada um desses outros processos para
que cada um desses outros juízes, eles determinem
o cancelamento da penhora que eles efetivaram.
Agora, é importante sempre ter em mente o
concurso de credores.
Por quê?
Porque o concurso de credores é o que
vai falar se vai sobrar algum débito daquele
imóvel para você ou não.
Mas eu vou pedir para que você guarde
essa curiosidade que você pode ter agora nesse
momento para a aula futura que a gente
vai ter especificamente sobre o concurso de credores.
Saiba que a consequência de uma penhora é
que a penhora ela vai ser cancelada por
determinação do juiz que determinou o leilão, ou
caso ele entenda que ele não pode cancelar
penhoras de outros juízes, de cada juiz que
determinou aquela penhora.
Agora, se vai ou não sobrar dívida do
imóvel para você, a gente vai aprender na
aula de concurso de credores.
Uma observação importante, em algumas matrículas, primeiro você
vai encontrar uma informação de que o imóvel,
que ocorreu um sequestro sobre aquele imóvel, ou
que ocorreu um arresto sobre aquele imóvel.
O arresto é uma medida cautelar para garantir
futura execução.
Recaem em todo e qualquer bem que possa
garantir a execução.
Depois ele será convertido em penhora.
Então, o que significa isso na prática?
Vamos supor, eu entrego uma ação cobrando um
valor seu.
Eu sei que você tem bens para me
pagar, mas pode ser que você, quando saiba
que eu entrei com aquele processo, você tente
se livrar dos seus bens para depois você
não ter nenhum bem em seu nome que
possa ser levado a leilão para me pagar.
Então, uma forma de impedir que você faça
isso, uma forma de impedir que você faça
a dilapidação do seu patrimônio é registrar o
arresto na matrícula do imóvel.
Então, o poder judiciário, ele apreendeu todo e
qualquer bem seu que possa servir para me
pagar futuramente.
Quando ao final daquele processo, realmente um juiz
te condena a pagar para mim uma quantia
X, mas para que eu não chegue ao
final desse processo e fique, e ganhe, mas
não leve, o juiz vai bloquear os seus
bens para que você possa futuramente me pagar.
Essa medida é o arresto, ela recai sobre
qualquer bem do devedor.
E o sequestro é exatamente a mesma coisa.
A única diferença das duas figuras é que
o sequestro, ele vai recair sobre um bem
específico.
Então, vamos supor, eu entrei com um processo
contra você para cobrar uma dívida que você
me deve, e você tem 20 imóveis.
Você não precisa ficar com seus 20 imóveis
bloqueados para me pagar uma dívida, porque pode
ser que somente um desses imóveis já seja
o suficiente para me pagar.
Então, o que o juiz vai fazer?
Ao invés de bloquear o seu patrimônio inteiro,
ele vai sequestrar um bem seu.
Ele vai bloquear um bem específico para que
aquele bem específico possa servir para me pagar
futuramente.
O sequestro, ele também deve ser registrado na
matrícula do bem.
Então, a diferença deles é que o arresto,
ele cai em todo e qualquer bem do
devedor, e o sequestro, ele cai em um
bem específico.
Ambos, depois, devem ser convertidos em penhora, porque
a penhora é o que possibilita que o
leilão aconteça.
A penhora é a efetiva conscrição sobre aquele
bem.
É a efetiva apreensão judicial daquele bem para
que um leilão possa acontecer.